[Music]
hi
mystery recapped here today i am going
to explain a mexican dark comedy film
called the noble family spoilers ahead
watch out and take care
the movie centers around a family of
four named the noble family the father
germaine is a wealthy mexican
businessman and has three children javi
barbie and charlie a few years ago their
mother died of a health issue ever since
the children have been living off the
money from her trust fund they throw
extravagant parties buy whatever they
want go on several vacations and use the
money carelessly none of them have
worked the day in their lives which
worries your man because someone has to
take over his business one day his only
daughter barbie is in a relationship
with peter a failed entrepreneur who is
20 years older than her he is hoping
that marrying her will provide him with
enough money to pay off his enormous tax
debt barbie oblivious to his actual
intentions is smitten with him on the
morning of her birthday several workers
come to decorate the house she
recognizes one of them as lucho the
nephew of their family made who once
lived in their mansion's servant quarter
in their teenage years barbie used to
trouble lucho by pretending to seduce
him lucho doesn't like her because of
her personality in the next scene we are
introduced to the middle child javi he
is the only child who is mildly
interested in taking over the business
after his father when he is not busy
partying with his friends he pretends to
work for the company however he does
nothing but come up with stupid and
unrealistic ideas all day that morning
he suggests they start a petrol home
delivery service german's business
partner kareem makes fun of him for the
absurd idea german thinks that giving
javi a tougher task might help build his
confidence he hands his son a file to be
sent to an associate the next day
then we are introduced to the youngest
son of the family charlie he is a
college hipster who skips his classes
almost every day he also hits on his
teachers and frequently gets in trouble
because of it like his siblings his
lifestyle consists of partying and using
his parents money in vain when jermaine
is in his office he sees a bill for his
children's expenses from the past month
looking at the numbers kareem warns him
against his children's careless spending
habits german knows that he has to teach
them the importance of money but doesn't
know how that afternoon javi brings his
friends on an impromptu trip to miami
disregarding the fact that he was given
an important task by his father in the
evening barbie is enjoying her birthday
party she sees lucho on the other side
of the room and asks him to clean a
stain off her dress lucho sighs thinking
that she hasn't grown a day since they
last met peter sees them getting close
and interrupts the conversation he
jermaine and barbie go to a private room
at his request he then asks german's
permission to marry his daughter
jermaine in turn questions him how he's
going to keep her happy when he doesn't
have a job barbie interrupts and replies
that they will use her trust fund
knowing that peter is not a good person
german disapproves of the marriage but
barbie doesn't back down she simply
walks outside and announces that she and
peter are engaged and are soon to be
married german is already worried about
his daughter but the problems add up
when he finds out have he ditched the
important meeting that he was assigned
to right after he gets a call from
charlie's college's dean saying that he
was caught having sex with his teacher
and was given a high five i mean was
expelled because of the stress germain
has difficulty breathing and is taken to
the hospital when his children come to
see him he pretends to have gotten a
heart attack he hopes that the siblings
will feel responsible for giving him too
much trouble but much to his
disappointment they start arguing about
a movie when they leave german makes it
his mission to teach them a lesson one
way or another he and kareem plan to
fake a bankruptcy and send the three to
live in the slums in the following scene
barbie is with her friend at a
restaurant javi is partying with his
friends as always and charlie is in a
meditation class barbie tries to pay
with her card but it gets declined she
has never had such a problem so she
doesn't know how to solve it at the same
time the brothers get a call asking them
to return home immediately by the time
they gather at home their phones have
been cut and a crowd is gathered outside
asking for money german arrives and
makes them jump over a wall to escape
once they are far enough from the house
he explains that he was cheated by
kareem who has fled with all their
company's money german is now broke and
a wanted criminal for fraud in the third
degree since the siblings are also the
shareholders of the company the police
are looking for them this means they
will have to refrain from contacting all
of their relatives and live a
low-profile life the siblings finally
realize the seriousness of the situation
german brings them to his father's old
house that is not listed under the
company's assets the house is in ruins
clearly abandoned for decades the three
who have never stayed in anything other
than luxury hotels are beyond horrified
german claims they will have to renovate
it with time as they earn money they eat
crappy street food for dinner while
discussing finances when asked how they
will earn money german suggests they
work for the first time in their lives
the following morning barbie tries to
take a shower but the faucet only
supplies dark brown dirty water she
instead uses hand sanitizer to sanitize
her entire body meanwhile javi goes to
his friends and asks them for money
promising to return it as soon as their
assets are unfrozen however the guys who
used to party with his money refused to
help him somewhere else barbie calls
peter and tells him they have to
postpone the wedding after finding out
about their situation he is distressed
that he couldn't profit off their money
when he had the chance charlie is the
only one who goes to look for a job upon
his father's request he easily gets a
job at a bank his boss is rude to him
because the position was supposed to be
her niece's ha rich nepotism beats
regular nepotism she threatens to fire
him any chance she gets when the family
reunites at the end of the day they
handed german whatever money they were
able to collect barbie has earned the
most but it turns out she sold havey's
watch for it moments later their
faithful maid maggie and lucho come to
the house to help them they also bring
clothes for the family to change into
lucho takes advantage of barbie's
situation to trouble her as she did to
him when they were teens upon his aunt's
request he provides her with a job as a
waitress in a restaurant that he works
at when javi asks if there is any work
for him too he is given the job of a
public vehicle driver the following day
is javi's first day of work everything
goes well until another vehicle cuts in
line before them and the driver makes
fun of him meanwhile barbie also goes to
the restaurant and is disgusted to see
chefs spitting on customers meals she is
made to change into a uniform in a
shared locker room when she retaliates
lucho claims that she deserves
everything she is facing currently
because of her unlikable personality as
much as i want to side with lucho this
is kind of illegal as time passes the
siblings start adjusting to their new
life cooking and cleaning for themselves
although they struggle initially they
soon get a hang of it havi's rivalry
with a bus driver continues for weeks
one day he tries to race him to a
parking spot and is stopped by the
traffic police barbie is not very good
at being a waitress she is mean to the
rude customers which causes them to walk
away without paying eventually she
learns to flirt for better tips one day
charlie makes a mistake at his banking
job and his boss calls him to her office
to his surprise she closes the door and
suggests he do something right to make
up for the mistake the two end up having
sex in the office
one night after dinner jermaine
discovers barbie trying to make herself
puke to maintain her weight he is in
shock to find out that she's been doing
it since she was in college and was
diagnosed with bulimia a few years ago
barbie laughs claiming that he'd never
had time for his children so she didn't
expect him to care german realizes how
absent he has been from his children's
lives until now somewhere else peter and
his friend are talking about how he
missed the chance to pay off his debts
he also tells the guy everything about
the bankruptcy and kareem fleeing with
the money peter's friend doesn't believe
him because kareem is right behind them
talking to someone peter registers that
something is wrong and begins to
investigate the next day lucho and
barbie go to the market together they
bond while buying groceries for the
restaurant and trying several street
foods meanwhile javi finds his
competitor bus driver and starts a fight
with him they suddenly stop after
finding it they both read the books by
the same author on talking to each other
they learn that their ambition in life
is the same to start a business of their
own a few weeks later the family earns
enough money to be able to renovate the
house while they're at it jermaine
mentions how bad heavy is at spelling
things javi reveals that he is dyslexic
and has gone to therapy for it german is
left speechless when told that he paid
for the therapy sessions he feels guilty
about having not paid attention to his
children's lives the next day at the
restaurant the owner throws a party for
his employees barbie and lucho dance and
eventually kiss at the same time peter
arrives at their house and meets german
he claims to know everything about
german's lies and threatens to reveal
the truth to his children scared that
they will hate him after finding out
german asks him what he wants just then
barbie arrives home and sees them peter
informs the family that kareem has
returned with the funds and their bank
accounts are working again this means
that they can go back to their old
lifestyle the siblings are overjoyed to
be able to return home german on the
other hand is blackmailed into staying
silent the family gets ready to leave
and barbie meets lucho outside she
reluctantly wishes him farewell and
leaves she believes that since peter
helped her in a situation like this she
cannot betray him and go to lucho the
next day jermaine goes to the office and
asks kareem for a solution he wants to
keep the secret from his kids but will
at no cost allow barbie to marry peter
barbie starts shopping for her wedding
even though her heart is not in it she
only does it because she feels indebted
to peter in the following scene jermaine
and kareem are in a meeting with peter
and a lawyer german offers peter money
to walk out of barbie's life however
peter is adamant about wanting to marry
her in the end german has to sign a
contract that says barbie's husband will
be authorized to use as much money as he
likes from her trust fund he still hopes
that peter won't be the said husband
following the meeting jermaine goes to
meet his family maid maggie she advises
him to tell his kids the truth because
the longer he hides it the longer they
will take to forgive him german trusts
her and decides to do the right thing
but he is unaware that somewhere else
peter is proposing to his daughter he
asks her to sign the marriage papers
immediately because he cannot wait
anymore barbie is nervous and unsure if
she even wants to marry him still she
follows his lead and goes to city hall
german calls his sons and asks them to
meet him immediately however when he
calls his daughter peter picks up and
cuts the phone call jermaine contacts
barbie's friend and finds out she is
about to get married he along with havie
and charlie rush to the city hall to
stop her they arrive seconds before she
signs the paper and are able to stop her
german finally reveals that they were
never bankrupt he lied to them because
he wanted them to know how difficult it
is to earn money he also reveals that
peter only wants barbie's money and has
been blackmailing him the siblings are
furious at their father for lying to
them they simply walk away without
saying anything after the commotion they
decide to move into the old house that
they were renovating they refuse to take
jermaine's help and build a life on
their own they work hard but their
father is not there to see it havie
along with his fellow bus driver open a
car wash his old friends try to
reconcile but he dismisses them
similarly charlie finds a girlfriend of
his own age and is in a happy
relationship barbie also goes back to
lucho and starts dating him on barbie's
birthday everyone gathers at the house
to celebrate someone knocks on the door
and barbie opens it to see her father
outside he wishes her happy birthday and
is about to leave but his children call
him inside and the family finally
reunites
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching